paul
[Musique]
premier plongeon dans les bassins pour
ses nageuses du 100 m nage libre
pendant trois jours les séries et les
finales du 29e meeting de natation de
l'océan indien se dérouleront dans le
bassin olympique de la piscine du
chaudron va quand même un très beau
plateau parce qu'on a le meilleur club
français avec des nageurs l'équipe de
france des nageurs sont plusieurs fois
titré aux jeux pour la france donc un
très bon niveau national et
international puisque son représentant
aussi de l'équipe de france ceci dit
peut-être des nageurs moins connus parce
que ce sont des nageurs en devenir mais
il faut savoir que la natation française
est en reconstruction
tous nos meilleurs nageurs qui étaient
très connus comme manaudou camille
lacourt et tous sont des nageurs furent
arrêtés il ya une relève qui se met en
place des nageurs qui sont moins connus
donc on a l'impression que finalement le
plateau est pas si les mecs ça c'est
parce que ce sont des gens qu'on connaît
un meeting qui regroupe les meilleurs
nageurs de l'océan indien et les futurs
espoirs de la natation française alizée
morel en fait partie
cette jeune nageuse réunionnaise
accompagné par le département grâce au
dispositif des sportifs de haut niveau a
remporté cette année le championnat de
france du 400 m nage libre sa famille
aussi donc savais que ça fait du bien et
ça donne un peu de peps pour la pour la
suite puisque je rentre dans une
préparation un peu compliqué à partir du
2 janvier donc
la ceni qui viennent regarder plutôt si
ces occasions d'échangés d'apporter des
paysages de c'est ça aussi le sport bien
sûr bien sûr on est là pour ça pour leur
vendre un peu du rêve en fait voilà pour
leur montrer ce que c'est par la
natation à haut niveau et tout ça et moi
et moi ça me fait très plaisir de
pouvoir enfin de fins de voir mais que
les petits peuvent l'admirer du coup va
du coup voilà c'est parce que je pense
que moi aussi mais j'étais à leur place
comme quand j'avais 9 10 ans et je
regardais les grands comme ça je me suis
enfin voilà genre à trop être comme eux
et c'est donc je pense que c'est
important pour promouvoir la natation et
commencé les préparations pour la
nouvelle saison
ce meeting est le premier grand rendez
vous pour les nageurs réunionnais ça
nous permet de rencontrer des gens qu'on
connaît pas
des spirées la boue avec des gens qu'on
prenne du temps et le niveau il est
comme en bas il ya beaucoup de forces
sur tous les gens qui viennent de
métropole et bas après ceux qui sont de
l'océan indien ça va enfin se sent à peu
près comme organisée par la ligue de
natation de la réunion le meeting de
l'océan indien accueillera près de 400
participants de toutes catégories les 28
29 et 30 décembre à la piscine du
chaudron
[Musique]